I'm think Donald Trump would be a good
president he wants to make a wall over
Mexico and in Mexico is a cool place
the president who keeps his promises to
the country is a good president
someone who's nice and tells the truth
all the time be good to others because
if they're not good to others what's
going to happen is they will call the
police
and would go to jail what other
qualities would make a good present
being an animal what kind of animal
monkey
I don't want Donald Trump time he's many
lies a lot big city the only reason he
wants to do it it's because he wants to
live in the White House and get more
money
get to start college for free and then
you just pay a little bit of money get
frit through the years like a $25.00 or
something now going to bed at 11 o'clock
go into bed at 6:00 a app the veteran
should be like paid more when there's
like after they're done serving like a
billion dollars so then so then when
they get back they can like buy a house
and food and then get a new job I don't
want to be the present haha
people say I should run home ah no like
they say you should be present like only
one main thing about that decision